okay could you please explain this i
hear this all the time in the manosphere
and it's she is not yours it's just your
turn
like what is that
that's like so
negative to me and i guess like as my
parents have been married for so long
i'm like
it kind of like makes me feel like weird
i guess
um like why do you think that's such a
common phrase is it because divorces are
mostly initiated by women
um
i think it's more of a coping sort of
mechanism i think that guys tell bros
that it's like hey bro don't worry she's
not yours it's just your turn sort of
thing because they don't know how to
dive into the uh evolutionary psychology
component of attraction and why men and
women make the choices that they do
so
it's convenient it makes people feel
better
um it's not that it's inaccurate i mean
it's just it's just a different way of
of like phrasing something else that
could be distilled differently but
um people get a again when when somebody
gets offended by a sound bite or a catch
phrase it's usually because it resonates
with them and it gets under their skin
right
does it get no i just
it doesn't really resonate with me like
it just it isn't really what i've seen
like
with my parents so i guess that's why i
don't like it because i'm like
it's it's like
you know it's just an interesting way of
of kind of saying well
you know women aren't that monogamous
you know like you could say she's not
yours it's just your turn or you could
say well women aren't particularly good
at monogamy right or you know there's
different ways that you could rephrase
it and it would mean the same thing it's
just it just happens to be that that's a
sound bite that resonates the most
okay fair enough um
another thing that it says you
are probably not her first choice
um
i
i have a little bit of a like isn't
everyone someone's second choice
like i mean like this is the way i think
about it right
if you like a supermodel and like an
average girl and he picks that out like
i feel like most guys would pick the
supermodel if given like both
choices you know
um
i can tell you where that came from
yeah that came from chris rock stand up
i think it was either chris rock or
chris tucker i think it was rock and he
said something like you know to the
audience he's like hey guys you know the
number one reason why your girl is
pissed off at you today because he's
kind of like working up to it
is you weren't her first choice and it's
like the audience audience you know
bursts up into laughter that's where
that came from and
the reason why they burst into laughter
is because for the most part when women
get into a marriage with a guy and it's
mostly you know long-term relationships
and couples when they're responding to
that question
women don't generally settle for their
first choice um we talked off air before
we started and you brought up the term
alpha widow right so most women have
been alpha widowed at some point in
their life meaning the guy that they
pined for that they were hoping to lock
down
didn't commit and walked so that's why
you know that you know you're not her
first choice joke you know tends to
resonate and you know everybody gets
such a kick out of it
yeah no i've definitely seen like the
alpha widow thing um
i guess like i feel like girls like get
over it eventually at some point
um
but no i guess i could kind of see where
that comes from a little bit
i just
i was just thinking about it the other
day and i was just like i feel like
everyone is someone's second choice like
at some point
you're not thinking about the same for
guys
yeah it's it's you know it's the same
for both sexes it's like you know uh
guys don't usually get the girl that
they want and women don't generally get
the guy that they want in a long-term
basis i mean it's it's it's kind of
across the board that's that's probably
one of the few things that are across
the board actually
okay um someone in the comments wants to
know
um
this is a black pill question ask him
why he thinks money is important if
looks are clearly the number one factor
well i'm not going to respond to black
pillars because they just try to bait
you with nonsense that's that's
absolutely absurd go watch my channel
read my book you'll get the answer
okay fair enough
see let me just talk about that for a
minute because these guys get so hung up
on looks okay that's all they focus on
oh if you're not a chad you're screwed
just don't do anything bro it's a waste
of time but all they'll do is sit around
all day
talking about women right they hate
women they can't get them or they say
they can't get them and all they do is
talk about them and they get mad at guys
that get them like me right now
so for perspective
you've seen my videos uh i'm about six
foot two 210 pounds i'm bald i have to
wear glasses to read [ __ ] because my
eyesight sucks i got third degree burns
all over my upper body my arms you know
blah blah i can go down the list i'm not
perfect
i don't have a problem with women
why because i've done the work
um
no well that's the thing about blackpill
is like i think there's some truth into
what they're saying like especially with
height for men like
like i'm six foot but i know how that's
not true no no no no i'm gonna squash
that because i had a roommate for about
eight years who was five foot five and
he was a slayer
okay
height matters yeah women want
height
they definitely seek that when it comes
to
getting the best genes
but there's lots of guys that are sub
six foot that do very very well with
women because they max out in other
areas right if you're short if you're
five foot five
be short jacked and rich with good game
okay you know you control what you can't
and you walk away from what you can't
that's that's the problem that a lot of
these doomers have is they get too
focused on oh you're screwed bud there's
nothing you can do man
no i was i was about to say like i think
there's some truth to it but at the end
of the day like what else are you
supposed to do you can like sit there
wallowing in it or you can like do the
best with what you got which i think is
like
the best solution for anybody you know
like i could sit here crying and saying
like oh like a victoria's secret model
would have more options than me but like
you know like who what how does that
help me you know
um but i agree with you like i think
girls just want someone taller than them
so like if you're five five like there's
a bunch of like five
foot to five five girls
that like would have have a problem i
can i can destroy that narrative of all
that women care about his looks like
there's a lot of really messed up
short guys even deformed guys
okay that have done great with women um
you can look up after this uh show sean
stevenson on my channel i did an
interview with him i think it's on the
playing the win cast there's a couple
months before he died
go watch that video with the interview
you can see exactly what he looks like
and you can see why he managed to land a
good-looking girl and marry her
right it's not all about looks do looks
matter absolutely they matter of course
they matter women select guys based on
you know what they look like because
they want the sexy sons you know lots of
research has been done on this
is it all that matters
no that's where they get it wrong
right no i definitely agree i actually
went to um
a pickup conference this weekend like
pua or whatever oh no you didn't
which one
i'm nosy so i just like i like to know
things um it was with on john anthony
lifestyle
oh well there's your first mistake right
there
um
and it was actually really interesting
to like
like even talk to guys that like sleep
with all of these girls and like talk
about what they want and like a wife and
even the guys that sleep with like the
most like
absurd absurd amount of girls like they
still want a girl like that doesn't
hasn't slept with a lot of guys
there's
you know what i'm just going to set that
aside because there's a lot of [ __ ]
that comes out of that that area of the
internet that's all been dispelled you
guys can go look it up if you search for
the right names and exposed
it'll certainly come up
okay yeah i don't know it was
it was interesting to be honest like
that was a very you'll see i'm gonna
have a video on it in a couple like
probably a week or two it was
yeah that's a different side of the
internet that i did not know
um okay let's see what other questions
do you think there is a shortage of
husbands or a shortage of wives right
now in the dating market
i'd say both because women have
incredibly high expectations of men
and there's there's very few men that
can take off those boxes for women
right um you know women like women are
the gatekeepers to sex like they decide
when intimacy happens men are the
gatekeepers to relationships so
uh there's there's a few
sorry
there's a good number of top shelf men
out there that um you know could take on
a wife or you know multiple women in
their lives and some of them do you know
some of them are married was a mistress
some are just monogamously married some
are in open marriages a lot of top shelf
guys out there
um
can basically exercise these options
because of who they are and what they've
done in life uh that being said there's
loads of beautiful women out there
there's there's probably more attractive
women than what there are top shelf men
so
i'll frame it that way because that's
what men look for they look for beauty
right beyond that you know if you're
talking about pair bonding on a long
term basis they have to have you know
cues of femininity they have to
basically you know be able to enter his
frame complement his life all that stuff
long list of stuff that we could talk
about some other time but yeah there's
there's um
there's a problem the the the fabric of
society has been torn apart
over this last century and some would
argue you know for the most part
terribly over the last few decades but
it's it's very very difficult for men
and women to form these types of healthy
long-term relationships because of the
state of things right now
um can you talk a little bit about um
true marketplace value that was
something that you said in
one of your videos do you mean sexual
marketplace value
yes yeah okay so smv is a term i think
rollo may have coined i'm not sure if it
came from somewhere else but all that
really means is like what's your value
to women you know to the opposite sex
and
women are evaluating you based on
looks your ability you know to create
resources you know
money basically is what that means
looks money well
the way that the red pill you know sums
it up is looks money game status
basically right guys that tick off all
of those boxes and are in high in all of
those areas will be highest on the
sexual market value scale and when
roller frames that he's basically saying
look guys peak in their mid to late 30s
women peak around 23
so we're on different places on the smv
scale um he's got it on a blog somewhere
on his uh website so you can look that
up there's an entire blog on sexual
marketplace value if you want to check
it out
um i actually don't this is one thing i
think i disagree with um with the
manosphere i i do agree like i think
that girls
smv
like that makes sense around 23. if if
anything like i would even say a little
younger
um
but for men like i don't think the
majority of men keep themselves in good
enough shape to like peak in their
mid-30s
uh you may not be tripping across these
dudes then maybe they're not coming
across your circle i don't know what you
do for a living where you're going right
all i see is a little picture of your
head right now so i'm not sure what what
access you have to these top shelf men
but there's lots of guys out there that
have got their [ __ ] together i got a lot
of them in my community right like we
have a lot of conversations on a regular
basis they're on my business here
they're entrepreneurs like these guys
are not [ __ ] around on apps like tick
tock and instagram and stuff like that
they're busy putting a dent in the
universe so you have to understand like
they're not as obvious as you think they
would be right
no that's why i said the majority of men
like what percent of men are really like
putting themselves in a position to be
high value i would say like not the
majority
um what i was thinking is like most of
the guys i went to college with like i
most of them like don't look better now
than they did like in college
you should get out there more
okay um what do you think of prenups do
you like do you think that prenups like
work in general like would you recommend
to guys to get married or do you think
it's too much of a risk
um so what time is it here i got about
another uh 10 minutes to get with that
good okay um so when it comes to prenups
i think i think what you need to do is
you need to broaden the conversation to
managing risk prenups are one part of
managing risk like
i'm a top shelf guy i got lots of money
got fast cars i got multiple businesses
blah blah blah uh if i'm going to invite
a woman into my life like let's say that
i'm i'm saying to myself okay i think
i'd like to father a few more children
um i need uh a feminine beauty to sort
of enter my frame and compliment me with
that one of the things that she would
have to do is sign a prenup it's not
it's it's very like the probability of
me finding a check that's on the same
financial level that i am is going to be
very very low so
the concept of a prenup needs to be
discussed if that's something that
you're going to do
another thing that you definitely want
to consider when it comes to managing
risk and we don't have a ton of time to
go through all of them but
i did a video i think this week it's
uploaded on my channel within the last
few days
and i go through the specific states
that are father friendly because one of
the things you got to understand is like
okay well if you're going to have kids
you're living in the west you know if
you're living in the u.s or canada or
something like that you're going to be
in an environment where half the time
marriages are going to end
right okay well you wouldn't jump out of
a freaking plane without a parachute on
you know just hoping for the best so you
have to take some precautionary steps
and one of the things i'd recommend guys
should do is entertain living in a state
that isn't going to make it hard for him
to parent his child or his children if
things don't work out
so it's so it's a broader question than
just prenups it's a question of how do
you manage risk when you're parenting or
fathering children